Sometimes, caffeine is a
bad self-medicating drug,
causing all sorts of problems.
But other times, it can be
really good for your brains.
Hey y'all, Trace
here for D News,
helping to validate your coffee,
tea, and chocolate addictions.
What do they have in common?
Caffeine.
Caffeine is an uber
popular stimulant
that people self-medicate
with all the time.
Thanks to its
proliferation, scientists
have been studying this
little molecule for a while.
We know it boosts people's
feelings of alertness, slows
dopamine reabsorption,
and now we've
got another bonus,
memory consolidation.
Memory consolidation
is the moving
of information from the
20 to 30 second short term
memory to the long term memory.
It's not the same
as memory retention,
which is the ability to recall
a specific bit of information.
Consolidation is usually thought
to take place during sleep.
In a new study in
the journal Nature,
neuroscience
explores how caffeine
could add to this process.
The researchers showed
non-caffeine consumers
a set of pictures.
And then afterward, gave them
either a 200 milligram caffeine
pill or a placebo.
200 milligrams is about what's
in a 16-ounce cup of coffee.
The reason they didn't give it
to them before the test is they
weren't testing
memory retention,
but memory consolidation.
They wanted to be sure
the caffeine didn't affect
the people's test
taking ability,
but instead, affected
if they forgot things.
24 hours later, the
same participants
were shown another
set of pictures
and were asked to
identify which were
in the second set and the first.
To stimulate a certain
brain process called
pattern separation,
a deeper process
than simple memorization,
the second set
was similar but not quite
the same as the first.
The results indicated
that those who
took the caffeine pill forgot
less and were better at picking
out the new photos,
showing caffeine
helped, although
they're not sure why.
So back to the lab, ho!
The practical takeaway is
you can help tell your brain
to remember a specific event
or maybe a bit of information
if afterward, you just get
a little bit of caffeine.
It's sort of like highlighting
a piece of your memory.
Maybe if you do that,
your brain will include it
in tonight's consolidation.
The half life of caffeine
is about six hours.
So if you were to drink the
200 milligrams of caffeine
that they're recommending for
like, a 10:00 PM study group
session, there would
still be 100 milligrams
in your body at 4:00 AM.
That can affect sleep quality.
So maybe it's better to
try this during the day?
Just saying.
I may have to do some
self-experimentation
to see how caffeine
boosts my own memory.
I already know it does
wonders for my attention span.
And if your attention
span is as short as mine,
you'll probably dig Scott
Bromley's Internet Rabbit Hole,
a brand new show launched on
our sister network, Rev3Games.
Scott will take you on
a fast-paced journey
through pop culture to prove
how everything on the Internet
is completely connected,
if you know where to look.
If Pac-Man was never
invented, Christian Bale
would have never been Batman.
Check out every Tuesday.
And if you like it,
why not subscribe?
Anyway, what were
we talking about?
Oh, right, memory.
So how's yours?
Mine is pretty bad
about a lot of things.
I can't remember what I even
had for breakfast last Friday.
No idea.
But I remember all
sorts of stupid trivia.
So tell me about it down below.
And that's what
those boxes are for.
Also, subscribe now.
You might forget later.